hi I'm Deidre Behar and tonight we're
celebrating the best in film at the 2017
Producers Guild Awards how proud are you
of this amazing woman
always yeah and the fact that all of
this brings attention to the film is
extraordinary
I'm ready for you guys to team up in
collab is that ever gonna happen us we
collab oh yes
Wow Lyon completely wrecked me what does
it mean to you to bring such an
emotional story to light the emotional
responses is what's just astonishing
because people come up and want to hug
you and they cry and they really connect
for you a second a second Oscar
potentially Devlin Oscar what does that
mean to you I just saw Deb for the first
time since he was nominated so what you
say to have got input I just did
congratulations can you believe it so
it's a view must be so pressure together
yeah and it's just amazing
congratulations you are an Oscar nominee
how does it feel
that's um insane just hearing that Oh
shots I'm still shot I love the theater
with mascara running down my face making
this movie was it just as God wrenching
for you absolutely I kind of gave it my
heart and soul and to kind of go on such
a deep emotional journey is this one the
fact that you know with we're saying
real people's words it makes it all the
more sacred amongst the et offices
you're our new favorite celebrity hunk
how are you handling all of this like
female attention I think that
deliriously I'm very grateful come on
you